HOW YOU DO IT.
>> I SAW YOU THE OTHER DAY
SAYING THAT ANYONE WHO ATTACKS
THE LGBT COMMUNITY, OUR LGBT
COMMUNITY YOU SAID WILL BE GONE
AFTER TO THE FULL EXTENT OF THE
LAW.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> I TALKED TO PEOPLE HERE NOT
FANS OF YOURS AND SAID THAT THEY
THOUGHT YOU WERE BEING A
HYPOCRITE, THAT YOU FOR YEARS
HAVE FOUGHT -- YOU BASICALLY
GONE AFTER GAY PEOPLE, SAID THAT
IN COURT THAT GAY PEOPLE SIMPLY
BY FIGHTING FOR MARRIAGE
EQUALITY FOR TRYING TO DO HARM
TO THE PEOPLE OF FLORIDA.
TO INDUCE PUBLIC HARM, I BELIEVE
WAS THE TERM YOU USED IN COURT.
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU'RE A
CHAMPION OF THE GAY COMMUNITY?
>> LET ME TELL YOU.
WHEN I WAS SWORN IN AS ATTORNEY
GENERAL, I PUT MY HAND ON THE
BIBLE AND SWORN TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THAT'S NOT A LAW.
THAT WAS VOTED IN TO OUR STATE
CONSTITUTION BY THE VOTERS OF
FLORIDA.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS DEFENDING.
HAD NOTHING TO DO -- I'VE NEVER
SAID I DON'T LIKE GAY PEOPLE.
>> BUT YOU DID -- DO YOU WORRY
ABOUT USING LANGUAGE ACCUSING
GAY PEOPLE OF DOING HARM TO THE
PEOPLE OF FLORIDA WHEN DOESN'T
THAT SEND A MESSAGE TO PEOPLE
WHO MIGHT HAVE BAD IDEAS IN
MIND?
>> ANDERSON, I DON'T BELIEVE GAY
PEOPLE --
>> BUT YOU ARGUED THAT IN COURT.
>> MY LAWYER ARGUED A CASE
DEFENDING WHAT THE SUPREME COURT
ALLOWED THE VOTERS TO PUT IN OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION.
>> YOU WERE ARGUING THAT GAY
MARRIAGE, IF THERE WAS GAY
MARRIAGE, SAME-SEX MARRIAGE,
THAT WOULD DO HARM TO THE PEOPLE
OF FLORIDA.
FLORIDA SIGNED IT.
>> IT WAS CONSTITUTIONAL TO PUT
IT IN THE CONSTITUTION.
>> ARE YOU SAYING YOU DID NOT
BELIEVE IT WOULD DO HARM TO
FLORIDA?
>> OF COURSE NOT, OF COURSE NOT.
GAY -- I NEVER SAID THAT.
THOSE WORDS NEVER CAME OUT OF MY
MOUTH.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU WERE ARGUING
IN COURT.
>> NO.
NO.
WHAT WE ARGUED WAS IT WAS IN THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
LET ME GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
MEDICAL MARIJUANA.
A 12-YEAR-OLD COULD GET IT IF IT
PASSED.
WE TOOK THAT TO THE SUPREME
COURT BECAUSE OF THAT LANGUAGE,
HOLD ON.
IF THAT PASSED, I WOULD DEFEND
THAT, AS WELL, BECAUSE IT'S MY
JOB TO DEFEND WHAT'S IN THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THAT'S WHAT IT WAS ABOUT.
>> THE HOTLINE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ON TELEVISION
WHICH ALLOWS FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SPOUSES OF THE DEAD TO GET
INFORMATION, WHICH IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT, APPRECIATE YOU
TALKING ABOUT ON THE AIR, HAD
THERE BEEN NO GAY MARRIAGE, NO
SAME-SEX MARRIAGE, YOU DO
REALIZE THAT SPOUSES, THERE
WOULD BE NO SPOUSES, THAT
BOYFRIENDS AND GIRLFRIENDS OF
THE DEAD WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
GET INFORMATION AND WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO VISIT IN THE HOSPITAL
HERE.
ISN'T THERE A SICK IRONY IN
THAT?
>> LET ME TAKE IT A STEP
FURTHER.
PEOPLE AREN'T RIGHT NOW WHO ARE
PARTNERS AND AREN'T MARRIED
OFFICIALLY AREN'T ABLE TO GET
INFORMATION SO WE'RE TRYING TO
ASSIST THEM IN GETTING
INFORMATION.
BECAUSE EARLY ON --
>> ISN'T THERE A SICK IRONY YOU
FOR YEARS WERE FIGHTING THAT
VERY IDEA?
>> I WAS DEFENDING THE
CONSTITUTION OF WHAT OVER 69% OF
THE VOTERS PUT IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> BUT THE COURTS, THE FEDERAL
COURTS SAID THAT'S NOT THE
CONSTITUTION AND YOU CONTINUED
TO FIGHT IT.
>> NO.
THAT'S WHY WE RUSHED TO GET IT
TO THE U.S. SUPREME COURT
BECAUSE WE NEEDED --
>> THERE WAS A FEDERAL JUDGE AND
YOU CONTINUED TO FIGHT IT AFTER
THE FEDERAL JUDGE RULED AND
SPENT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS FIGHTING IT.
>> WE RUSHED TO GET IT TO THE
SUPREME COURT.
YOU KNOW WHAT TODAY IS ABOUT?
HUMAN BEINGS.
TODAY'S ABOUT VICTIMS.
>> IT IS ABOUT GAY AND LBZ
VICTIMS.
>> IT IS.
LGBT VICTIMS.
>> IS IT HYPOCRITICAL TO PORTRAY
YOURSELF AS A CHAMPION OF THE
GAY COMMUNITY WHEN -- I'M JUST
REFLECTING WHAT GAY PEOPLE TOLD
ME THEY DON'T SEE YOU AS THIS.
>> I I DON'T PORTRAY MYSELF AS
ANYTHING BUT TRYING TO HELP
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
AND WHO HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
AREN'T GETTINGING THE SERVICES
THEY NEED.
THIS PRNING, YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE
BEEN DOING?
TRYING TO FIGHT WITH A FUNERAL
HOME FOR OVERCHARGING FAMILY